sorry I'm late
don't be sorry just don't be late
Vincent Sobel meet Dinah Drake
Tina Boland his name cover name Tina
Boland I'm going to kill every last one
starting with flora
hey everybody we got a flash crossover
and the stabia studious version of Black
Canary that we've seen on the show so
far
not counting black siren because
technically doesn't count as a black
canary because it's a different version
of the character but for everybody
hoping for Black Canary versus black
siren this season it sounds like they've
gotten to that place regardless of how
you think it's going to end up because I
don't think it's actually gonna end up
going down that way there's a new round
of that blast ring giveaway all you have
to do to enter that'd just be a
subscriber and share the video using
those tools on the watch page so let's
do top 10 WTF comic-book Easter eggs and
it sounds like we have a better picture
of what's gonna be happening with the
villains in the back half of the season
because of that really critical piece of
information that they got about why Kate
and James has been coming after Oliver
which is a lot of people suspected was
completely faked so let's start with
that because that's probably the most
important thing the whole season has
been turning around this like I'm gonna
come for you and make you suffer because
you caused my son to die like he
literally thinks that Oliver killed him
so there are a couple big questions
about this one they found out the
footage was faked because the footage
makes it look like it's literally Oliver
firing his bow into his son who's about
18 19 years old and that's it like
that's the end of it but at that time
Oliver was recruiting Black Canary in
Hub City so we know it wasn't him the
footage was faked they also put two and
two together the same person that faked
the footage of Oliver at the beginning
of the season is the same person that
faked this footage so there's somebody
on the show that we probably been
watching this whole time someone under
our noses that's been tried to
manipulate Kate and James to go after
Oliver it really right now Anatoly and
Richard Dragan are the only other two
people that it could be unless it's like
some surprise twist person that we
haven't been saying this whole time one
of the future episodes is titled the
greatest trick the devil ever pulled
which is very usual suspects like the
Keyser söze like who's the real villain
that's been hiding in plain sight this
whole time I think most people are
assuming that it's Richard Ragan because
he's one of the few comic book
characters that they're doing this
season who actually rises to that level
in the comics like somebody that you
could actually call a big bad second big
question is is that when Kate and James
finds out that this footage is fate
Oliver isn't really responsible is he
gonna call off his dogs and then the
real villain gonna
myung-kil kate and james like if it's
gonna be richard dragon will Richard
dragon then try to kill Kate and James
because he doesn't continue to go after
Oliver but unless they're trying to just
totally pull a fast one on us
now you kind of see what they were doing
with the vigilante arc like the last
couple of episodes he's been helping
them out the rest of team evil finds out
they kill him for it and they're making
this big question about whether or not
Laurel is gonna start helping team arrow
out like is she going to get this
redemptive arc and until they pronounce
vigilante dead at the hospital at the
end of the episode sorry there's nothing
that they could do all of her confirms
that he's dead I thought that they were
gonna try and pull a fast one on us like
wait a minute maybe he's pretending to
be dead because he had that really
important line when he started going
after Dinah where he told Kate and James
I know which buttons to push and he
seemed like he was genuinely going to
try and work a counter-attack against
them not just straight-up help them out
which is what ended up happening we
haven't seen a whole lot from Anatole
but he has this sort of black siren type
of relationship that she has with
Quentin with Oliver Queen where they
used to be brothers but now they're
fighting against each other because of a
big rift that they had maybe a black
siren is gonna get a redemptive arc that
Anatole will slowly walk back the hate
that he has for all of her like they'll
find a way to bridge that gap so when
you're looking at the surprise new
villain or the true villain of the
season that's why I think that Richard
dragon is probably the stronger
candidate because he's pretty much the
only character on Team evil right now
who didn't used to be really close with
one of the members of team arrow but
either way somebody was trying to set up
Oliver Queen and somebody's been
manipulating Kate and James he will
probably find out before the last batch
of episodes maybe not right away but
sometime before episode 16 or 17 so that
they can focus on the real villain there
were a couple pretty big Easter eggs in
the episode too they keep mentioning
playstation4 William has been playing
injustice to this whole time I think
because there's an integration going on
like Microsoft provides all the
computers for arrow so they feature them
in episodes but it's kind of like a
product integration thing where they pay
money to have them be used on the show
but Oliver also mentioned Aruba like
they were talking about their honeymoon
oh where take a honeymoon after this but
you also remember that Aruba was very
significant to legends of tomorrow at
the end of season two
in the beginning of season 3 so all
across the back half of season 2 people
alike what are we gonna do after we
solve this insurmountable problem of the
Legion of Doom once we get rid of
reverse-flash and the spear of destiny
well why don't we just go to Aruba and
it was sort of just an offhanded comment
about how they would go find a beach
somewhere and chill out on vacation then
after they actually solved the problem
everybody else was in such a different
place psychologically and emotionally
that they went their separate ways
except for heatwave who would just
completely stuck on the ideas like
damnit I'm gonna have my vacation so
that's where he showed up at the
beginning of season 3 he'd been chilling
out there for the past three months
[Music]
idiot
neither refill my margarita or gallon my
light this is a private beach
listen pal what I just in general the
people on arrow I think we all expect
the black siren we'll get that
Redemption arc but she says like that's
not me your daughter is not the person
who is me they'll find some way to
bridge that gap like they're teasing
that she's eventually going to find some
sort of redemption they just want to
have this black siren versus Black
Canary arc which is why they had her
melt vigilantes brain inside his skull
badass kill but I was kind of hoping
that they would go for the John
Carpenter thing and just explode his
head like a watermelon maybe because
it's not cable they're not allowed to
get that graphic whatever either way his
brains just leaked right out of his ear
after that everybody poor went out for
those Argus guards that they just
casually killed at the beginning of the
episode too
but the really big news obviously the
Superbowl is this weekend there's going
to be a bunch of big Superbowl trailers
like there always is the ones that I
know for sure it'll be Star Wars on
Monday they'll be Westworld season 2
Mission Impossible then probably some
Black Panther infinity war is supposed
to come in the next couple of weeks
there's a confirmed venom trailer and
confirmed Deadpool - that won't drop at
the Superbowl but will drop with black
panther in the next two weeks so both
this weekend and then also in the next
two weeks there will be a bunch of big
comic boat trailers dropping don't worry
I'll do videos for all that stuff my
next video today will be that Westworld
trailer then I'll do some new infinity
war and and obviously some new flash in
DC Marvel stuff this weekend like I said
there's a new round of that flash ring
giveaway I'll just name the winner when
I post new DC this weekend click here
for my non-spoilery black panther
reaction and click here for that brand
new blast trailer thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight